Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen blicken auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen im Männerfußball. Da ist wieder so einiges passiert. Es gibt sogar eine Meister-Entscheidung. Reden wir jetzt gleich drüber in Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Das hier ist der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass mit unserem Blick auf die Europäischen Ligen. Die Ligatur ist mal wieder fällig. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf masterdome.social. Freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und freue mich sehr auf meine Runde. Später hören wir noch Uli Hebel, aber jetzt begrüße ich bei mir Mario Rieker. Hallo Mario. Dann Alexi Menuge. Hallo Alexi.
Bonjour, à tous et tous.
Und Alex Truica ist auch hier. Hallo Alex. Sehr schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Wir wollen gleich auf die verschiedenen Ligen blicken. Vorher möchte ich aber noch loswerden. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Bitte unterstützt uns finanziell. Und eine ganz wichtige Ansage habe ich da noch zu machen. Wir haben ja schon mehrfach kommuniziert, dass unser altes Konto, das FIDOR-Konto, das noch auf das Rasenfunk einzuliehen lief, dass das nicht mehr benutzt wird für den Rasenfunk jetzt, dass ihr unbedingt eure Überweisungen ändern müsst. Das haben doch nicht alle getan, obwohl eigentlich jeder jetzt inzwischen mindestens eine 1-Cent-Überweisung mit der Bitte, das Konto umzustellen erhalten haben sollte. Denn jetzt wird es aber dringend. Denn dieses Konto gibt es noch 12 Tage, dann wird es abgeschaltet. Die Fidor-Bank macht nämlich dicht. Das wussten wir auch schon. Das war einer der Gründe, warum wir uns ein neues Konto geholt haben. Also jetzt wird es langsam eilig. Ich habe auch gesehen, es gibt auch einzelne von euch, die jetzt doppelt auf Fidor überweisen. Da habt ihr einfach dann die falsche Bankverbindung genommen. Also bitte guckt euch das mal an. Auf rasenfunk.de/kontoerfahrtihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und alle, die jetzt sagen, Mensch, Fidor, da wäre ich so gern mit dabei gewesen. Ja, dann unterstützt uns gleich aufs neue Konto. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubhilft euch weiter. Danke für alle, die uns unterstützen. Jetzt schauen wir rein in unsere Ligen. Und ich habe ja schon angekündigt, dass wir einen Meister hier verkünden dürfen. Nicht so ganz überraschend, deswegen ja auch schon zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und es wird jetzt auch nicht an den Menschen da draußen vorbeigegangen sein, Mario, dass Napoli Meister geworden ist. Denn das war eben, wenn auch mit Ansage, aber doch ein historisches Ereignis. Das erste Mal seit 33 Jahren.
Das ist auch wild. Da habe ich tatsächlich noch zwei Sachen. Eine, die mir vorhin bei Napoli durchgerutscht ist, die ich finde, die wirklich lustig ist, dass die hatten ja eh schon vier oder fünf Trikots in dieser Saison, inklusive Valentinstagstrikots etc. Bei der Meisterfeier hat der Präsident dem Trainer ein Trikot überreicht, wo so Konterfeier von Spalletti drauf waren und viele dachten, dass es irgendwie ein Unikat, das er für ihn hat drucken lassen. Mitnichten. Diese Trikots gibt es jetzt in 33-facher Ausführung. Jeder Kaderspieler hat ein eigenes Trikot. Das kann man pro Stück für 150 Euro erwerben. Spielberechtigt sind sie mit diesen Trikots nicht, aber man kann sich jetzt auch ein Trikot sozusagen mit Bildern von Diego Demme drauf kaufen. Oder dem dritten Ersatztorwart. Und vielleicht auch Juwe-Thema. Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es bei Juwe reinpasst, dass es auch wieder eine Schublade ist, die ich schnell aufmache. Aber vielleicht ein kleiner Cliffhanger. Das dürfen Marius oder Christian dann beim nächsten Mal besprechen. Es bahnt sich eventuell wieder ein kleiner Schiri-Skandal an in der Serie A. Da hat ein Linienrichter das Gespräch mit dem Schiedsrichterbeobachter nach einer Partie aufgenommen, der im Wortlaut gesagt hat, ich habe es viel in der Serie B und C beobachtet. Danke an die Freunde aus Turin und Rocky. Das ist der Schiri-Boss. Eventuell gibt es da Fetternwirtschaft auf Verbands-Ebene, aber wäre noch nie vorgekommen, glaube ich.
Ja, und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht die Schublade, welchen Landes du da gerade aufgemacht hast. Also das könnte auch sehr gut die deutsche Schublade sein. Fetternwirtschaft bei Schiedsrichtern, das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Wer war noch mal am Armee? Na ja, googelt das, die jüngeren Hörerinnen und Hörer. Du musst nichts sagen. Sagen muss jetzt nur noch Alex etwas, denn wir wollen noch ein letztes Mal auf La Liga blicken. Wir haben ganz viel über Barca gesprochen, erstaunlich viel über Lionel Messi. Jetzt müssen wir, weil ansonsten sliden wir nämlich auch noch die Realfans in die DMs. Das kann ich jetzt nicht gebrauchen. Rest in peace, my inbox, das sage ich dazu nur. Also müssen wir jetzt natürlich über Real auch noch sprechen, Alex. Aber du hast ja auch gute Gründe dafür. Welche denn?
Ja, der erste Grund ist, sie sind frisch gebackener Pokalsieger, denn am letzten Wochenende ruhte ja La Liga, denn da war das Pokalfinale Copa del Rey Finale und Real Madrid hat die Copa gewonnen gegen Osasuna. Gegen das aufmüpfige, kleine, tapfere Osasuna. Aber eben für das Team aus Pamplona hat es nicht ganz gereicht. Der Underdog war eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte, der zum zweiten Mal überhaupt erst in einem Finale stand. Pokalfinale, der noch nie ein Pokal gewonnen hat. Also irgendein. Von daher waren da die meisten Herzen, glaube ich, der neutralen Fußballfans eher Osasuna zugetan. Aber Real hat das eben abgezockt gemacht, unter anderem mit einem sehr starken Vinicius, der zwar kein Tor geschossen hat, aber einfach da auf links eine Wucht war. Und wie stark der ist, konnte der ein oder andere geneigte Fußballfan dann auch am Dienstag sehen in der Champions League. Da war er auch nicht ganz so schlecht. Also Real Madrid ein Pokal gewonnen und vielleicht rauf und dran den zweiten, nämlich den weitaus größeren ja auch, zu gewinnen oder zumindest auf dem Weg zu sein in der Champions League da mal wieder ins Finale vorzustoßen. Also von daher aktuell Real Madrid ganz gut unterwegs, würde ich sagen.
Bevor wir über die Champions League sprechen, lass kurz bei dem Copa del Rey Finale bleiben. Ich habe eine unglaubliche Freude und Euphorie über diesen Titel gesehen, die mich als Banausen gewundert hat. Also war das etwas so besonderes für Real, diesen Pokal zu gewinnen?
Ich dachte kurz, das ist Ironie.
Ist das ernst?
Nee, das war ernsthaft. Aber dann bin ich vielleicht einfach nur nie das Kerne auf dem Leim gegangen, weil der hat sich extrem gefreut.
Okay, gut, dann war das bei ihm.
Könnte sein, könnte sein, weiß ich nicht. Ich hatte das Gefühl, es wird nicht ganz so zelebriert bei Real Madrid. Wie gesagt, nur ein sehr subjektives Empfinden, wie, keine Ahnung, wie in Eintracht Frankfurt das Ding in Deutschland gewinnen würde oder...
Okay, okay, da bin ich halt wirklich in meiner Timeline. Da waren noch so ein paar Frauenfußball-Journalistinnen mit dabei. Da gibt es auch eine, die ist quasi, die war auch früher mal Spielerin bei Real, die ist auch total ausgerastet. Aber gut, da hätte ich vielleicht mal ein bisschen meine Quellen hinterher fragen sollen.
Also einen Platzsturm gab es nicht im La Catucha, in Sevilla, im Finalstadion.
Gott sei Dank, denn sowas wollen wir nicht sehen, Alex. Das sind Bilder, die wir nicht sehen wollen.
Das wollen wir nicht sehen. Nee, gab es nicht. Es war eher gedämpft. Es ist halt doch nur der Pokal. Und vor allem für die großen Clubs, wobei so viele große in Spanien gibt es ja nicht. Da gibt es ja eigentlich nur zwei ganz, ganz große. Für die ist das halt meistens eher nur ein Trostpreis. Meistens, auch wenn es teilweise ja der einzige Pokal sein könnte. Aber ich glaube, die Stimmung wäre etwas weniger oder etwas euphorischer gewesen, hätte Ossasuna, wie gesagt, seinen ersten Titel gewonnen. Also nee, das war eher gedämpft, fand ich. Die Zeremonie, die Jubelbilder Real Madrids auch natürlich, weil einfach drei Tage später, vier Tage später, und jetzt können wir den Bogen spannen, Champions League gegen Man City anstand, und das einfach das größere Spiel für Real Madrid ist, ohne Win und Aber.
Also, ich konnte das Spiel leider nicht sehen. Ich habe allerdings in der Halbzeit...
Das ist ein Skandal.
Statistik gesehen, ja, ich weiß, es ist ein Skandal, aber ich bin ja hier und nur der Moderator. Ihr müsst ja die Antworten geben. Ich habe aber die Statistik der Halbzeit gesehen, und da hatte, glaube ich, City sechs Schüsse und Real Madrid einen, und Zwischenstand war eins zu null für Real. Wie war denn das Spiel dazu? Am Ende ist es ja ein eins zu eins geworden, weil Kevin de Bruyne noch den Ausgleich machen konnte.
Ja, aber solche Zahlen erzählen halt nicht immer die ganze Wahrheit. Da gehört halt viel, ja, viele Nuancen sind da dabei. Also ich persönlich fand, das war wirklich ganz, ganz hohes europäisches Niveau. Ich glaube, die anderen Jungs hier im Call geben mir da wahrscheinlich recht oder sind da meine Meinung. Das war wirklich, wie der Name schon sagt, City Real klingt ja eh nach einem vorgezogenen Finale, wenn wir ehrlich sind. So war fand ich das Spiel auch ganz, ganz hohes sportliches Niveau. Und dass Real Madrid in der Champions League abgezockt ist und dass sie nicht 80 Prozent Ballbesitz brauchen und 18 Torschüsse, um mal ein Tor zu machen, sondern eher aus sehr wenig, unfassbar viel machen können, weil sie unglaublich abgezockt sind, da erzähl ich niemandem was Neues. Von daher, City war fand ich besser im Spiel, hat einen guten Auswärtsauftritt hingelegt, wie ich fand, war sehr, sehr fokussiert, sehr konzentriert, anders als zum Beispiel in München, wo ich sie nicht gut fand. Ja, da hatten sie das 0-3 oder das 3-0 im Rücken aus dem Hinspiel, klar. Aber im Viertelfinale bei den Bayern fand ich City eher wackelig, ängstlich, zaghaft. Das war, fand ich jetzt anders im Bernabéu. Da haben sie eher mit dieser Selbstsicherheit, die sie ja sowieso eigentlich immer haben, zumindest in der Premier League, sind sie aufgetreten. Aber es ist nun mal Real Madrid. Da gibt es einmal eine Balleroberung, einmal einen Burst nach vorne von wem auch immer. Kann man winken auf Vinicius und er haut das Ding knallhart rein. Das ist einfach das ganz, ganz große europäisches Niveau, Real Madrid in der Champions League. Aber ich fand, City hat trotzdem sich gefangen und war ja nicht minder hässlich das Tor von de Bruyne. Das war auch ein ganz, ganz hohes Niveau, würde ich sagen.
Ich fand das Spiel nicht so positiv wie du. Alex, es war ein gutes Spiel, aber nicht so hervorragend, wie du sagst.
Na ja, es war kein 5-5 mit 37 großen Chancen.
Nein, wir brauchen keine 5-5, um zu sagen, es war ein gutes Spiel. Das war nicht bei dir, aber 1-1. Ansonsten haben wir, ohne das Tor von de Bruyne, der wirklich sensationell war, war de Bruyne nicht so gut in diesem Spiel. Haaland war nicht zu sehen, wie oft die Großen spielen, außer gegen Bayern. Und was mich ein bisschen skandalisiert hat, ist, dass zwei deutsche Nationalspieler hätten vom Platz fliegen müssen, nämlich die Herren Rüdiger und Kroos. Die haben nicht mal gelb gesehen, also Kroos nicht zumindest. Das darf auf diesem Niveau nicht passieren. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob da die UEFA wieder mit dabei war. Man braucht alle Top-Spieler im Rückspiel, obwohl Rüdiger nur gespielt hat, weil Militao gesperrt war, glaube ich. Aber was der mit seinem Ellenbogen gegen Gündogan macht, Frechheit und das Gleiche mit Kroos auch wieder gegen den armen Gündogan.
Arme Gündogan, von seinen Kollegen mal trittiert, na, Nationalmannschaftskollegen oder Ex-Kollegen bei Kroos.
Das scheint nicht so beliebt zu sein.
Er hatte auch seine Ausländer-Setzung mit Kimmich mehrfach. Und Goreska natürlich gegen Bayern für die Finale.
Man könnte sagen, Vorgeschmack auf nächste Saison, falls Gündogan beim FC Barcelona landet. Aber das kann man ja noch beobachten. Ob da etwaige Revalitäten dann auch weiter ausgelebt werden. Vielleicht war das nur ein Vorgeschmack für Herrn Gündogan. Mal sehen. Ja, das sah ich jetzt nicht ganz so eng. Auch die Rüdiger-Szene fand ich jetzt nicht so dramatisch, um ehrlich zu sein. Und an die Kroos-Szene erinnere ich mich nicht. Aber dass Toni Kroos gerne mal davon kommt. Der hat halt eine Aura, der Mann. In Spanien vor allem. Das wird eigentlich noch mal anders gesehen. Von daher verzeiht man ihm vielleicht gerne mal das eine oder andere Foul. Das ist schon okay so.
Ja, ganz kurz dazu. Ich habe schon auch das Gefühl, dass eine sehr großzügige Spieleitung angesetzt wird jetzt bei den letzten K.O.-Duellen auch in der Champions League.
Das ist ja nicht selten in der Champions League, Mario.
Genau, da sagt man so, der Schiri kriegt Sonnenbrand auf dem Handrücken. Somit immer ruhig, ruhig, wie der Mann. Mir hat der Schiri insgesamt nicht gefallen. Der war irgendwie so Verkehrspolizist. Sehr viel mit den Armen rumgewädelt und so.
Hat ein Deutscher gepfiffen?
Ich teile aber den Eindruck, ich hätte Real tatsächlich noch passiver eingeschätzt, aber dann eben mit diesen Nadelstichen. In der ersten Anfangsphase waren sie ja auch so unterwegs, aber haben dann auch tatsächlich bewiesen mit ein, zwei Situationen, wie schnell sie für Gefahr sorgen können. Was dann auch, glaube ich, muss man einfach mal, hört sich blatt an, aber das macht ja was im Kopf des Gegners. Ah, es ist real. Sie kommen einmal da und Benzema wäre zur Stelle. Und danach, teils in der zweiten Halbzeit, waren die ja auch wirklich irgendwie drauf und dran. Ich hatte das Gefühl, die wollen jetzt definitiv den Heimsieg und sind gar nicht so sehr zurückhaltend, wie ich sie erwartet hätte. Insgesamt glaube ich trotzdem, ja in der Summe, wenn du das Spiel in Gänze betrachtest, ist das 1-1 für real gar nicht das optimale Ergebnis. Da wäre mehr drin gewesen. Weil auch wenn Rüdiger sich da, Alexi hat schon zum Teil recht daneben genommen hat, der hat auch Harlan komplett in der Tasche gehabt. Das musst du auch da mal hervorheben. Ich war deswegen aber auch ehrlicherweise gestern über das Spiel in Mailand so erfreut, weil ich doch dann auch den Eindruck hatte, oder in den letzten Wochen Gesprächen mit Kollegen, dass es dann so bei Real abgezockt ist. Und die machen dann das, was sie können. Und ich dachte, wenn jetzt das Mailand Derby 0-0 ausgeht, dann ist wieder der deutsche Journalist dabei, das Wort Catenaccio in die Headline zu packen. Also das ist so zweierlei Maß. Und weil du einmal auch dieses schöne Konstrukt des vorgezogenen Finales benutzt hast, ich würde mich dann doch auch sehr freuen, wenn trotz aller Buchmacherquoten, und man wahrscheinlich dann eine 10er-Quote fürs Sieg von Inter oder Milan bekommt im Finale, würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn die italienische Mannschaft dann mit Taktik wie Roberto Di Matteo, sorry Max, wie 2012 dann die Champions League gewinnen würde.
Traue ich Inter zu tatsächlich? Würde ich zutrauen?
Ich wäre auch hässlich, hässlich 1-0.
Ach du, Milan auch mit dem Torhüter.
Ich habe sie nämlich in Porto gesehen. Also ich war nicht in Porto, aber gegen Porto gesehen. Ich glaube, das ging ungefähr in die Richtung, oder? So ein 1-0 aller Roberto Di Matteo.
Genau, das können sie ja auch. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht die Grundherangehensweise, aber sie können es eben auch. Ich finde dann immer solche Spiele, und auch gerade bei Real ganz oft, so schön zu erkennen, dass halt so auch Fußball funktioniert.
Wie hat Real die letzte Champions League gewonnen? Das war auch nicht so prickelnd. Finale gegen Liverpool. Drei Courtois standen da im Tor, hatte man im Gefühl. Oder ein 3-Meter-Courtois.
Das ist jetzt aber wieder so eine Frage, die kann nur von einem deutschen Podcaster kommen. So darf man nicht auf dieses Finale blicken. Real ist ja auch... Ich habe einen Witz gemacht, das war auch nicht offensichtlich.
Das war ja nicht mal als Kritik gemeint. Das war nur eine Feststellung, dass es verschiedene Wege gibt, Fußballspiele zu gewinnen. Manchmal brauchst du eine gute Abwehr, manchmal einen guten Torwart, manchmal beides. Manchmal einen abgezockten Stürmer oder Flügelspieler. Optimal hast du alles, und dann gewinnst du ein großes Spiel. Keine Kritik ans weiße Lager oder an Herrn Groß.
Genau, ich wollte auch nur einen Witz machen. Aber ich finde, an Teams wie Real, da siehst du nicht nur, was feste Achsen bewirken. Ich meine, schau dir Groß und Modric in diesem Mittelfeld an. Das ist halt einfach absurd, welche Ruhe die ausstrahlen. Aber das ist auch etwas, was im Leistungssport oft unterschätzt wird. Die Ruhe, während du einen Puls von 200 hast und das Adrenalin schon reinkickt und alle nur auf dich gucken, das macht dann tatsächlich den Unterschied. Dann gibt es Teams, die vergeben Chance um Chance um Chance und werden eigentlich auch immer aufgeregter. Das ist sogar schon City passiert, obwohl die eigentlich aus Ruhe heraus, also die ganze Fußballphilosophie von Pep Guardiola, beruht ja auf Kontrolle, um eben quasi systematisch sich Chancen zu erziehen. Und du brauchst aber manchmal, in manchen Spielen, brauchst du einfach nur die Ruhe vorm Tor. Die zum Beispiel auch Milan nicht hatte gegen Inter, in den wenigen Situationen, die zu Chancen hätten werden können. So stimmt es eigentlich. Da waren die auch fürchterlich aufgedreht. Und Real ist halt einfach der große Junge, der angeblich in der U15 noch spielen darf. Er wirkt aber viel größer und erwachsener. Und der zockt das halt einfach in Ruhe aus. Und der lässt sich halt einfach nicht zur Seite schubsen. Und der lässt sich auch nicht verunsicher von einem Rückstand. Und das ist halt eine Qualität, die ist halt schwer in Statistiken zu messen. Aber vielleicht viel wichtiger als so manch anderes.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich vorhin auch meinte, mit überfordert bei Milan. Also war dann, wir sind in der Nähe vom Strafraum. Jetzt oder nie? Und die sind jetzt leider sehr weit davon entfernt. Aber es wäre natürlich auch irgendwie, ich habe dann ein Interview bei, ich glaube Reihe Uno mit Carlo Angelotti am Dienstag gesehen nach dem Spiel. Wir sind dann auch nach dem Derby, aufs Derby ansprechen und er sagt, certo, uno, due, forza Milan. Wenn Angelotti dann da gegen Milan das Finale spielen würde, das hätte schon auch natürlich was. Solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Aber wirklich, ausschließlich der Fußball. Wir werden es ja hier beobachten, denn wir werden tatsächlich nach dem Champions League Finale noch eine Ligatur aufnehmen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir kommen nicht dran vorbei. Ich habe jetzt diese Regelmäßigkeit hier gestartet. Ich habe mich so sehr an euch gewöhnt. Das muss jetzt einfach sein. Wann genau und so weiter, das kriegt ihr dann alles mit. Bis dahin wird ja auch noch ein Rasenfunk-Royal aufgenommen, unter anderem. Aber da werden wir unter anderem über dieses 1-0 von Milan gegen Real im Finale dann sprechen können. Oder wie auch immer es werden wird. Jetzt aber sind wir tatsächlich am Ende angekommen. Ich danke euch sehr. Das war eine unheimlich interessante Runde. Es hat mir große Freude gemacht. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker, den Ed Remedem auf Twitter. Danke dir, lieber Mario. Hört alle Serie am Ohre. Und hört natürlich auch Tiki Taka, den Podcast, bei dem Alex Truica mit dabei ist, der so auch auf Twitter unterwegs ist. Danke dir, lieber Alex.
Sehr gerne, danke es ebenfalls.
Und bei Alexis Menuge kann es noch eine Frage der Zeit sein, bis er auch seinen eigenen Podcast hat. Ich habe ihn jetzt auch im Nachholspiel-Podcast gehört. Sehr schöne Folge, Alexi. Schön, dass du hier warst und sag uns halt Bescheid, wenn du dann dein eigenes Projekt gestartet hast. Das ist ein Bummer zum Schluss, aber gut. Wenigstens geht es mit einem Highlight weiter. Hier hört ihr jetzt gleich Uli Hebel. Jetzt bei mir ist Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du Zeit für den Rasenfunk hast.
Immer sehr gerne, grüß dich.
Grüße dich auch, wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Und da hatten wir einen fantastischen Feiertagsspieltag, der ja nur stattgefunden hat wegen der Krönung von King's Stars. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Es ist ein Bank Holiday Monday, die gibt es immer mal wieder so verstreut in England. Ich kann dir aber gar nicht genau sagen, da haben wir intern auch immer diskutiert. Ist das so oder ist das nicht so? Ich glaube, die gibt es öfter mal. Aber mich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn es nur deshalb war.
Dann hätte diese Gründung wenigstens eine gute Sache gehabt, nämlich fantastische Spiele. Ich lese einfach nur die Ergebnisse vor und du darfst mir dann alles sagen, was ich dazu wissen muss. Fulham gegen Leicester 5 zu 3, Brighton gegen Everton 1 zu 5, Nottingham Forest gegen Southampton 4 zu 3. Da war was los.
Ja, da war echt richtig was los. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich jemals an einem Tag so viel Spektakel erlebt habe. Und was ja alle drei Spiele eint, ist, dass bei allen drei Spielen, bei einem sogar zwei, absoluter Abstiegskampf ausgerufen war. Und es darum ging, dass Big Points gemacht werden können oder vielleicht sogar müssen in einigen Fällen. Also Nottingham Forest gegen Southampton. Das letzte dann an diesem Montag. Das ist ein absolutes Endspiel gewesen für Southampton, weil die eh schon den Anschluss verpasst haben. Und uns einklar war, würden die jetzt nicht gegen Nottingham gewinnen. Eines der noch schwächeren Teams im verbleibenden Abstiegskampf. Dann wird es nichts für die. Und genauso kam es dann, dass die am Ende 4-3 verlieren. Das war jetzt noch vom Verlauf her eines der, ich sage jetzt mal normaleren Spiele, auch wenn es Southampton auch daran kam.
Das wundert mich, weil ich habe nur gesehen, 19 zu 9 Schüsse für Southampton, Ergebnis 3 zu 4. Da dachte ich mir, okay, das lief irgendwie nicht so.
Nee, das ist aber eigentlich in den letzten Wochen oft so. Das Southampton gar nicht so schlechte Leistungen bringt. Aber es reißt halt im Verlauf der 90 Minuten immer ab. Aber so wie es lief, dass Northampton im Forest 3 1 führte, dann kommt Southampton noch mal einigermaßen normal ran. Also im ersten Spiel z.B. Fulham gegen Leicester, da war ja Fulham schon mit 3-0 davon. Und dann machen sie es noch mal spannend. Wobei das das Team ist, muss man auch ehrlich sagen, Fulham, die sind ja eigentlich im Urlaub, weil da geht es nach oben um nichts mehr, nach unten um nichts mehr. Deswegen kann sowas da vielleicht noch mal vorkommen. Aber die haben jetzt auch nicht die Sterne vom Himmel gespielt in den letzten Wochen. Und Brighton gegen Everton ist aus dem Grund krass, weil Everton... Also, ich sage es jetzt mal, wie es ist, die Saison ist fürchterlich. Und die letzten Jahre sind fürchterlich. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich jemals so eine fußballerische Leistung Evertons gesehen hätte. Das war jetzt auch nicht so, dass die den wunderschönsten Kombinationsfußball gespielt hätten. Nur haben die, das war wirklich eine Sean Deitch Masterclass, die haben einfach alles darauf angelegt, dass sie im Konter Brighton im 1 gegen 1 schlagen. Das war gar kein Restverteidigungsthema bei Brighton oder so oder irgendwas, sondern das war einfach nur, sie haben es hinten darauf angelegt, dass sie in die Duelle kommen im Umschalten und die hat Everton im ersten Durchgang sang- und klanglos gewonnen und hat damit Brighton wirklich fast weggespült aus dem Stadion. Und Brighton wiederum spielt ja um die europäischen Plätze, weswegen das umso erstaunlicher ist, dass Everton ein Team, das sieben Mal in Folge nicht gewonnen hatte, dann plötzlich so eine Leistung hat. Was aber wieder zeigt, es ginge ja im Grunde bei Everton, wenn sie wollten.
Ja, wenn vielleicht auch der Spielverlauf passt. Ich meine, es hilft natürlich, wenn du in der ersten Minute schon mit 1 zu 0 in Führung gehst, auswärts, und dann deine Kontertaktik quasi sich auch manifestiert, weil dann muss der Gegner auch kommen. Also Brighton hätte gar keine andere Wahl gehabt. Wie sieht denn die Situation, wenn wir mal kurz beim Abstiegskampf bleiben, und da können wir vielleicht noch drüber reden, über Europa, was du ja auch schon gerade so ein bisschen mit angesprochen hast. Also Southampton ist jetzt so gut wie weg. Die haben 8 Punkte Rückstand auf das rettende Ufer. Wir haben den 35. Spieltag also nur noch 9 Punkte zu vergeben. Die nehmen wir raus. Dann Leeds, Leicester sind aktuell Vorletzter und Vorvorletzter mit 30 Punkten. 2 Punkte Abstand sind es zu erwarten. Da kann also ja doch noch was gehen. Und wir haben ja gerade bei Leeds auch wieder ein bisschen Veränderung.
Ja, also Leeds hat jetzt, das ist der denkbar dämlichste Zeitpunkt für einen Trainerwechsel, den man sich vorstellen kann. Für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben, da hat ja Jesse March gearbeitet, dann ist Javi Gracia für ein paar Wochen installiert worden. Ich glaube, das haben wir hier auch mal ganz kurz angedeutet, wenn ich mich komplett täusche. Gracia hat probiert, wie der SC Freiburg zu spielen in der Premier League mit einem Kader, der aufgebaut ist auf absolutes Hauruck. Entsprechend hat das solala funktioniert. Ich habe mir das schon gedacht, dass es in die Richtung gehen könnte, habe aber irgendwie auch verstanden, worum es geht. Und dann hat Leeds jetzt noch einmal vor dem Manchester City Spiel wohlgemerkt, alles abgeschnitten, was so da war. Das heißt, nicht nur den Trainer Javi Gracia, sondern auch Viktor Orta, den Sportdirektor, den ich nach wie vor für einen wahnsinnig fähigen Mann halte, weil der äußerst gut vernetzt ist, ein gutes Auge für Spieler hat und auch die Verpflichtungen von denen hinbekommt. Man kann jetzt darüber streiten, ob alles richtig war in der ganzen Amtszeit Jesse Marsch. Da haben sie den Kader extrem umgebaut. Ich finde nicht, dass vieles richtig war, von den Einzelspielern her. Ich glaube aber auch, dass das das war, was Jesse Marsch wollte. Und er hat ihm diesen Kader hingegeben. Jetzt hat Orta sich für Gracia entschieden, und das war jetzt wohl der Besitzerschaft eins zu viel. Man muss auch dabei wissen, bei Leeds ist das jetzt nicht normale Besitzerschaft, sondern da wabert jetzt schon seit eineinhalb Jahren die 49ers Group, also von den San Francisco 49ers, die Besitzerschaft, die da schon Minderheiten hat und an sich nur noch darauf wartet, die Mehrheiten übernehmen zu können. Woran es da ganz genau hakt, weiß niemand. Aber das wird irgendwann kommen, entsprechend haben die auch schon ein ganz schön gewichtiges Wörtchen, damit zu sprechen. Und aus Angst vor dem Abstieg, ich glaube, das ist ein ziemlich klarer Panikknopf-Move, hat man jetzt da nochmal gesagt, okay, egal, alles auf eine Karte und die heißt Sam Allardyce tatsächlich. Und mit Sam Allardyce gehst du ins erste Spiel gegen Manchester City und überraschungsgemäß verlierst du und hast jetzt deine Ausgangslage auch nicht zwingend verbessert. Naja.
Was muss ich denn zu Sam Allardyce wissen? Ist es ungerecht, wenn ich sage, der Peter Neurora der Premier League?
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Also das Ding ist, bis West Bromwich Albion vor ein paar Jahren, da war er auch eigentlich schon im Ruhestand und kam zurück, hat er zumindest diese Feuerwehrmann-Sam-Aufgaben immer gut gelöst. Jetzt hat er den Zauber aber auch verloren. Oder ansonsten ist Sam Allardyce Click and Rush. Kick and Rush, Entschuldigung. Das ist so Automatismus. Und das war's. Ehrlich gesagt, es scheint jemand zu sein, der eine sehr einfache Idee von Fußball hat. Mir hat Jan Kirchhoff das mal ganz ausführlich erzählt, dass das schon jemand ist, der einen positiven Einfluss auf Spieler hat, der eine gute Ausstrahlung hat, weil er jedem Spieler exakt eine Aufgabe mitgibt, die schleift er denen ein. Und die müssen sie dann umsetzen. Und das war's auch schon. Und damit fühlen sich aber Spieler durchaus wohl, weil es halt nicht mehr kompliziert ist. Nur, wir haben jetzt auch 2023 und nicht wie damals bei Jan Kirchhoff. Und da war es schon antiquiert, 2015 oder so. Sodass ich irgendwie sehr, sehr starke Zweifel an einem Wechsel habe, der jetzt auch Lizia binnen 14 Monaten von Marcelo Bielsa auf Sam Allardyce bringt. Also ich glaube, das ist allen klar, das wird schwierig, dass das was wird. Jetzt sind sie aber immer noch in Reichweite. Das ist klar. Also die sind immer noch in der Nähe der Nicht-Abstiegsplätze.
Ja gut, und sie haben halt zwei Heimspiele noch gegen Newcastle und gegen Tottenham. Natürlich auch gute Gegner. Und dann das Auswärtsspiel gegen West Ham, die im Grunde ja fast raus sind. Die werden bis dahin wahrscheinlich raus sein aus dem Abstiegskampf. Also vom Spielplan her könnte da noch was gehen für Liz.
Ja, ich habe die zwei Heimspiele echt kompliziert, weil für beide Tottenham und Newcastle geht es ja noch sogar um die Champions League. In der Theorie bei Tottenham nenne ich es nur die Champions League. Und West Ham ist raus. Die haben jetzt gegen United gewonnen. Also zum zweiten Mal in Folge wirklich gepunktet. Das heißt, die habe ich auch raus. Und das wissen wir auch seit den Wochenende. Crystal Palace und die Wolves sind rechnerisch auch durch.
Das heißt, dann haben wir noch Lester, Everton und Nottingham realistischerweise, die sich eben alle in so einem Drei-Punkte-Korridor da unten drin bewegen. Was ist zu denen noch zu sagen?
Also Lester hat auch noch mal einen Trainer gewechselt, Dean Smith. Ich finde, dass das eigentlich ganz gut aussieht. Das Problem bei denen ist, es scheint eine total verunsicherte Mannschaft zu sein. Anders kriege ich es nicht mehr erklärt, weil es strukturell inzwischen okay aussieht. Tats ja auch teilweise bei Brendan Rodgers. Und ich glaube, wenn das nicht klappt für Lester, dann muss man irgendwann mal über die Transferpolitik sprechen, dass sie einfach Abgänge nicht ersetzt haben und auch noch nicht mal im Winter, wo man schon wusste, dass es jetzt auf eine ganz, ganz komplizierte Phase zuläuft, dass sie da nicht wenigstens ein oder zwei Transfers gemacht haben. Ein komischer Kader, der eine komische Unwucht hat. Da sind einzelne richtig starke Ausnahmespieler wie Madison zum Beispiel dabei. Und dann gibt es Positionen, die sind durchschnittlich besetzt. Und das reicht einfach heutzutage nicht mehr. Bei Everton habe ich schon mal kurz gesagt, bei Everton gibt es einen Cheatcode im Abstiegskampf, wenn der gesund bleibt. Und das wahre jetzt mal vier Spiele in Folge ist Dominic Herbert-Luin, der alleine den Konterfußball möglich macht, den Everton spielt, weil er sich wirklich gegen jeden einzelnen Innenverteidiger der Liga durchsetzen kann, plus wahnsinnig schnell ist. Das heißt, wenn der drauf ist, kann man auch die langen Bälle spielen, umschalten, zweite Bälle, das ganze Standardprogramm, das ist dann möglich. Plus Everton hat sich auch noch mal ein bisschen verändert, sind jetzt im Pressing etwas, zumindest situativ, etwas aggressiver. Bisschen riskanter, also wirklich nur, soweit man das unter Sean Deisch sagen kann, ein bisschen riskanter geworden. Und das hilft aber schon, tut ganz gut. Und die haben dann auch nochmal Spiele drin, wo man denken könnte, ja, kann was werden. Bei Nottingham, das ist ehrlich gesagt für mich so, ich werde überhaupt nicht schlau aus denen. Einerseits mag ich Steve Kupas, ganz abwartendes Spieler, die spielen ganz oft ein 4-5-1 gegen den Ball. Und total passiv, aber dafür kompakt. Heißt aber, dass nach vorne selten was geht. Und immer, wenn ich das erzähle, hauen sie ein Viertore-Spiel raus. Wie jetzt am Bank Holiday Monday. Und das sind natürlich wichtige Punkte. Nichtsdestotrotz, also für mich ist es so, es ist weg. Bei Leeds mache ich mir große Sorgen. Und Nottingham glaube ich irgendwie an dir auch nicht.
Okay, das ist doch mal eine konkrete Vorhersage. Und gleichzeitig, wir haben es jetzt nicht bei jedem erwähnt, aber Leicester z.B. schüttet auch noch gegen Liverpool und gegen Newcastle, erwarten jetzt dann gegen City, Nottingham noch gegen Arsenal. Gleichzeitig werden diese Spiele im Keller auch das Rennen um Europa, Titelkampf will ich jetzt nicht aufrufen, ehrlich gesagt ausrufen, aber auch den Kampf um die Champions League noch beeinflussen. Und da hat sich ja auch ein bisschen was gedreht. Du hast es vorhin schon angesprochen. Brighton jetzt mit dem Rückschlag, die haben zwei Punkte Rückstand aktuell. Auf Tottenham, die liegen auf Rang 6. Liverpool auf Rang 5, haben aber den Anschluss an die Champions League-Plätze. Das haben wir hier in der Liga Tour noch nicht so wirklich aufgenommen. Manchester United, ein Punkt nur vor Liverpool. Newcastle ist drei Punkte vor Liverpool. Und dann kommen halt die großen zwei Arsenal und City, also die großen zwei dieser Saison. Wie sieht die Lage im oberen Segment aus? Wem gibst du da die besten Chancen?
Also ich fange jetzt mal von oben an, von Platz 3. Ich glaube, da gibt es ja noch ein leichtes Rennen drum. Inzwischen tatsächlich Liverpool wieder, erstaunlicherweise. Newcastle und Manchester United. Ich bin immer noch so, also zum einen hat zwar jetzt Newcastle verloren gegen Arsenal, hat aber eine ganz ordentliche Leistung gezeigt. Für mich ist das das Stabilste all der genannten Teams. Ja, Liverpool in den letzten Spielen ist stabiler und nach einem leichten Systemumbau spielen jetzt auch diese klassische 3-2-5-Struktur, die wahnsinnig gut zum Kader passt und auf einmal zwei, drei Problemchen löst. Tryter Alexander-Arnold kann mehr in die Mitte gehen, kann damit z.B. erstens seine defensive Schwäche kaschieren, weil er natürlich dann schon bei Ballverlust etwas kompakter steht, wenn er als sozusagen inverser Flügelverteidiger spielt. Auf der anderen Seite hast du Mohamed Salah, der jetzt mal wieder Diagonalbälle nehmen kann, die volle Breite für sich ausnutzen kann und endlich wieder mal den Ball am Fuß haben kann. Das hat er ja vorher eine ganze Zeit lang nicht, weil sie Hauruck gespielt haben im Umschalten plus. Jemand wie Curtis Jones z.B. kommt raus. Großes Problem bei Liverpool nach wie vor die Mittelfeldregionen gewesen. Und wenn er mit so einem 4-3-3-Mittelfeld spielt, dann kommen so ein dynamischer Achter wie Curtis Jones z.B. nicht so zum Tragen, der macht gerade einen Riesensprung. Das sind so die Gründe, warum es bei Liverpool gerade wieder richtig gut läuft. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt das Momentum sieht, ist Liverpool vielleicht das stabilste Team. Wenn man die ganze Saison sieht, ist Newcastle stark. Und ich habe immer gedacht, dass die nirgendwo hingehen. Auch in der kurzen Phase rund ums EFL Cup, das erste Pokalfinale. Ich glaube im Februar gab es mal eine schwächere Phase, ergebnistechnisch. Ich glaube aber, dass Newcastle die 3 macht. Und dann würde es nach meiner Metrik einen Rang-4-Kampf geben. Und das ist jetzt die Frage, bin ich jetzt vom Momentum so beeindruckt, weil United jetzt zwei Mal Folge 0-1 verliert. Und nach wie vor die alten Probleme hat, dass es eben mal Phasen gibt, wo es einfach nicht funktioniert. Auch mit David de Gea glaube ich einen Minus haben in diesem Kampf um Platz 4. Und weil Liverpool eben gerade gut aussieht. Und jetzt kommt das zum Tragen, was ich immer die ganze Saison über gedacht habe. Ja, es gibt ein paar Probleme bei Liverpool, aber ich habe immer geglaubt, sie sind einen Transfer oder eine Umstellung davon entfernt. Wir haben ja hier auch mal darüber gesprochen, dass ich immer das Gefühl hatte, ich glaube, ich muss denen jetzt was anderes geben, was die sicherer werden lässt. Hat er gemacht. Und wenn man vorher schimpft, muss man jetzt auch loben. Ich glaube fast sogar, dass Liverpool das noch packt.
Das sieht doch positiv aus. Und das würde ja auch bedeuten, dass Jörg Schmadtke dann als neuer Sportdirektor mit der Champions League planen kann. Kannst du mir dazu irgendwas sagen? Ich habe das einfach nur gelesen. Schmadtke zu Liverpool. Ich habe gecheckt, ob es der Postellon war. War es nicht. Und mehr weiß ich darüber nicht. Weiß man denn auch als Kenner schon mehr über dieses Gerücht?
Also tatsächlich kann ich auch nicht wirklich viel dazu sagen. Mich hat das absolut kalt erwischt, wie jeden Einzelnen oder jeder Einzelne wahrscheinlich zu Hause. Ich glaube, ich habe es am Samstagabend gelesen und hatte da noch einen Boxkampf vorzubereiten und war schon total müde und habe gedacht, okay, bei Twitter gibt es ja keine blauen Haken mehr. Ich habe vielleicht einfach nur die Quelle nicht richtig eingeschätzt. Und dann kamen logischerweise auch ein paar Fragen gleich. Hast du das gehört oder kannst du das sagen? Also ich wusste auch nicht mal genau, wo ich jetzt da ansetzen soll. Außer bei Matt Law selber vom Telegraph, der das ja rausgebracht hat. Und recht viel klüger bin ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Also alles, was man weiß, ist, die sprechen. Mir war auch neu, dass Klopp und Schmadtke befreundet sind. Gut, jetzt kennt man nicht jede Freundschaft im Fußballbusiness, aber ich würde mal tippen, das ist jetzt einfach so der Reim, den ich mir draufmache, dass Liverpool ja einen neuen Sportdirektor braucht, weil erstes Jahr Michael Edwards gegangen, vor einem Jahr, dann ist Julian Ward aufgerückt vom technischen Direktor zum Sportdirektor. Der will jetzt aber mal eine Pause vom Fußballgeschäft haben und jetzt musste Liverpool relativ schnell überlegen, ok, wen nehmen wir, vielleicht auch tatsächlich nur zu Überbrückungszwecken. Und da kam jetzt eben diese Personalie Schmadtke. Das heißt für mich zum einen, dass wahrscheinlich mal Klopp gefragt worden ist, wen könntest du dir vorstellen? Es gibt ja auch die Möglichkeit, dass Schmadtke das als eine Art freie Mitarbeiterverein macht und nur in beratender Funktion tätig sein könnte. Das ist das eine. Und zum anderen heißt das aber für mich auch. Und das ist für mich vielleicht fast sogar die interessantere Auswirkung dann jetzt, zumindest dieser Anfrage mal, dass Jürgen Klopp nicht plant, irgendwo hinzugehen. Gab es ja durchaus Spekulationen in der Zeit, als es nicht so gut lief. Aber ich würde tippen, dass das bedeutet, ne, der hat vor dann noch drei, vier Jahre zu bleiben. Und Schmadtke kann dann, ich glaube immer noch, nur zu Übergangszwecken helfen. Ich finde das nach wie vor wild. Also es ist viel, viel Komisches passiert in dieser Fußball-Saison finde ich. Auch gerade in England. Roy Hodgson zurück, Sam Allardyce übernimmt nur als Beispiel. Oder Frank Lampert zu Chelsea, wo ich echt gedacht habe, okay, jetzt haben sie alle ihren Verstand verloren. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass Schmadtke schlechte Arbeit macht. Ich kriege es einfach nie zusammen. Schmadtke und Liverpool. Nicht in 180.000 Jahren wäre ich da drauf gekommen. Wir hätten jetzt eine 50er-Liste machen können. Und den wäre da nicht drin gelandet.
Ja, gut. Dann gucken wir uns das an. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein bemerkenswertes Gerücht. Deswegen konnte ich es nicht ohne uns angesprochen lassen. Aber wir werden es ja sehen. Uli, ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Das war kurz und knackig, aber sehr, sehr meinungsfreudig. Und ich glaube, man kann sich auf den Saisonendsport in der Premier League wirklich freuen. So hört es sich zumindest an.
Das ist eine der spannendsten Konstellationen der letzten Jahre. Zumal ja oben auch noch nicht alles. Ich bin schon auch bei dir. Das muss man jetzt nicht klein diskutieren. Aber es ist nicht vorbei. Und wenn Everton noch mal so eine Leistung wie gegen Brighton bringt, dann wünsche ich mir auch viel Spaß bei City.
Das wird nämlich das nächste Auswärtsspiel von City sein. Wir gucken es uns an. Und man kann dann bei Click & Rush natürlich in deinem Podcast zusammen mit deinem Bruder Jogi Hebel das alles ganz genau nachhören. Danke dir, lieber Uli, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war eine lange Ligatur. Ich werde den Link zu dem Tweet, den Mario vorhin angesprochen hat, den werde ich in die Shownotes packen, wenn euch das interessiert. Und ansonsten hören wir uns hier wieder an dieser Stelle in der nächsten Woche. Da geht es dann um die Frauenbundesliga und um die zweite Männerbundesliga. Aber es gibt ja viel zu hören beim Rasenfunk. Es ist auch ein Tribüngespräch rausgekommen, was ich euch sehr empfehlen möchte. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao!